One of the trickiest things about testing software is that it's hard to know when you've done
enough testing and the fact is, it is really easy to spend a lot of time testing
and to start to believe that you did a good job and then to have some really nasty bug show up
that are triggered by parts of the input space that we just didn't think to test.
So let's look what's really going on, so we're going to start with the
domain range diagrams that we known off.
We're going to have some test cases into domain and after a while
we're going to start pretty good about what we're been doing.
What's going to turn out is without really knowing it, our testing is being compliant to some small part
of the input domain and the problem, is that even the small part of the domain may contain
an infinite number of test cases or else a finite numbers of test cases
that is large enough that its for practical purposes.
It's not distinguishable from infinity and of course what's going on is we're going to do test cases
other parts of the domain we didn't think to test, putting the results and outputs that are not okay.
It really depends on how we've broken up the input domain.
For example, let's think about the case that we're testing Therac-25 radiation
therapy machine that I used an example in the last lecture.
It's not might be the case but all of the inputs that we are going to test, the once in this region
are the once where we happened to type the input to the machines slowly.
We simply didn't realize that there's a whole other part of the input space
that has to be treated differently that happens when we type the input fast and of course
its in that region where we triggered the raised conditions that we're leading to massive overdoses.
Similarly, if you remember from lecture one,
we have a small Python program called the Python runtime to crash.
The distinguishing feature of it seem to be a large number of cascaded if statements.
It's pretty easy if we're testing Python programs to remain in the part of this space where for example
we have <5 nested in these statements.
Over here is another region containing programs with 5 of more if statement nested and these are ones
that cause for example, the Python virtual machine to crash.
To take an even more extreme example, let's say that we're testing some software
that somebody has inserted in the back door in.
Well in that case, there's going to be an absolute infinite test of all part of the input domain.
Maybe wherever here that triggers the back door cause remember if your putting a backdoor in code
you don't want to trigger it accidentally and that's going to lead to something
extremely bad happening over here.
We didn't tested inputs triggering the  back door because we just didn't know it was there.
So what we'd really like is some sort of a tool or some sort of a methodology
that if we are in fact testing only a small part of the input domain for a system what we really like
is some sort of an automated scoring system that looks at our testing effort and says to us
something like, your score is 14 out of 100.
Your not doing a good job testing the system. Keep trying.
And that's what today's lecture is going to be about.
It turns out there's a lot of reasons we do not want to know the sign of score to our testing effort.
Probably the main one is that this helps us find part of the input domain that need more testing.
So for example, if we can increase our score by testing this part of the domain,
we're naturally going to be led to do that and our testing efforts will improve.
Other reasons to assign a score to a testing effort are that we might be able to argue to a boss
which is some sort of a certifying authority that we've done enough testing.
Similarly, we might want to argue that the system we're developing has not been tested well enough
but its not yet safe to deploy and that it needs more testing and a testing score can provide
a numerical justification of that sort of way.
Probably, it would be nicer if we could take a large test suite one maybe that takes several days to run
and identify parts of the test suite that are completely redundant.
That is to say parts of the test suite that tests exactly the same parts of the input domain.
Even though they occupy parts of the input domain have roughly the same testing effect on the system
to assigning a score to our testing efforts and let us do that as well.